hi I'm Eric Voss and after seeing alien
covenant for me one of the big lingering
mysteries surrounds the xenomorph
creature itself just like in prometheus
covenant introduces a new variation on
alien but there are also Xenomorphs and
eggs and facehuggers in this movie so
where did these guys come from so in
this video I'm gonna explain every form
of the xenomorph that we see an alien
covenant why they're different from
aliens and other movies how they evolved
who or what created them and why some
parts of them look different when they
see each other in showers and spoiler
warning if you haven't seen alien
covenant yet I'm gonna ruin it for you
I might actually make it a little bit
better for you since it might make more
sense now but either way you should just
go watch the movie first okay so the
main thing to understand is that as of
alien covenant we have now seen three
main types of aliens they may look and
function similarly but they're different
not all aliens are the same first
there's the classic xenomorph from the
original line of alien movies second the
Deacon who showed up at the end of
Prometheus and third the new Neil Moore
from alien covenant so let's start with
the xenomorph the one we know the most
about
so the Xenomorphs evolutionary cycle of
course begins with the OVA morph the egg
these are produced by the xenomorph
queen the eggs contain the base hugger
which latches on to a host and then
after it impregnates this hosts the face
hugger exoskeleton detaches and the
alien later takes the form of the chest
burster and leaves the host quite
gracefully and then it outgrows at husk
and grows very quickly into the large
deadly xenomorph that cocoons new hosts
for future gestation by new facehuggers
we also know that the xenomorph takes on
the DNA of the host that it just states
inside
remember in alien 3 a face hugger
attached to a dog producing a
four-legged xenomorph nicknamed the
runner now i know it seems like eggs
face huggers and xenomorph looking
aliens do show up an alien covenant
implying that there must have been a
xenomorph queen somewhere to lay those
eggs and there's more to that that i'll
talk about in a bit but first we need to
talk about these other two forms because
they help explain how we get to this
point alien covenant the second form is
the Deacon from Prometheus so quick
review of the creatures that we saw in
Prometheus it started with the black
liquid a bio weapon created by the
engineers to induce genetic chaos and a
species actually intended it to use it
this species the human race because they
were unhappy with the monsters that
their creations ended up becoming and
like the xenomorph this black liquid has
a unique reaction to each living thing
it encounters so for example when it
made contact with indigenous worms on
Elbe 2 to 3 it resulted in this hammer
peed Cobra like creature with acidic
blood so the black liquid can be inhaled
or ingested as it was by Holloway when
David put a drop of it in his cocktail
then when Holloway had intercourse with
Shaw the result was the trilobite squid
creature which Shaw removed via
caesarean section also quite gracefully
and that baby trilobite matured
immediately into a room sized squid with
tentacles used to orally impregnate
hosts namely this engineer which
resulted in the deacon and at the time a
lot of people thought that this was a
xenomorph but it wasn't the back of a
head is more pointed which the Deacon
uses to burst out of the engineers chest
also its mouth is pretty different
there's no inner mouth like tongue that
snaps out and its teeth are more
human-like now this was the last time
that we saw the Deacon but this black
liquid is what eventually results in the
third type of alien the Neo morph in
Alien Covenant so we learned in this
movie that David after levy and LB two
to three arrived on the engineer planet
and released this dirty bomb of black
liquid on the engineers below he later
confesses that it wasn't an accident
as he initially said he did it on
purpose because he's obsessed with
overthrowing his creators to experiment
and create the perfect organism so this
caused the genetic chaos and violent
mutations that we saw only bits of and
Prometheus this time on a wide scale
eventually wiping out all the non
botanical life on this planet that's why
when the Covenant crew explores his
planet they don't hear or see any
animals the black goo also resulted in
these mutant egg sac like plants which
release microscopic airborne spores that
instinctively grouped together and
target a host and planting through the
ears nose or mouth as they do with lead
word and Hallett then there's a similar
gestation process and another graceful
exit except this wasn't the easy Namur
chestburster
this is a blood burster and it grows
into the adult white colored neo morph
that we see
so just to clarify yes the Neo morph was
kind of indirectly created by David they
were one of his many biological
experiments in his pursuit of the
perfect organism but what about these
eggs that he has like how do they get
here underneath the engineer city are
they you know more pegs does this mean
David created the xenomorph - okay so
lots of big questions here let's unpack
all this so it's still pretty unclear
whether David created the classic
xenomorph as we know and love it but it
does seem like that he created the proto
morph that is the early stage xenomorph
that popped out of Captain Oram and low
pay and covenant this Pro Tamura alien
is also probably what popped out of shop
David revealed that he used her body in
his experiments to produce this new
alien so again these Pro timorous aren't
full Xenomorphs yet notice how their
eggs look a little different and even
though the proto morphs follow a pretty
similar facehugger stage the appearance
of the chestburster is pretty different
so rather than the fleshy snake form of
the classic movies which I spent money
on a stupid toy of the chest Burstein
proto morph looks like a smaller baby
Groot version of the fully grown adult
form of course these could have just
been design changes by Ridley Scott but
I think that he wanted to show that
these aliens weren't exactly the classic
xenomorphs at least not yet in their
evolution so why add this in-between
stage my theory is that David is still
perfecting this creature so for example
when he released the facehugger on Oram
maybe he realized that the gestation
period wasn't long enough like it seemed
like it was only a few hours tops
meanwhile in Alien the gestation period
with Kane seems much longer he wakes up
and returns to seemingly normal health
tricking him into this false sense of
security so that he can hang out with
other potential hosts over dinner so
it's possible that that longer gestation
period is a genetic feature that David
adds later on with a new chest burster
that just states more slowly and
discretely that could increase the
likelihood of the host carrying it
somewhere new where it can spread and
multiply and yeah that's a pretty good
way of thinking but it would make
perfect sense to a heartless Android
like David now the other big question is
where did these eggs
from so there are a few possibilities
one is that these eggs were the result
of David's experimentation like David
created the eggs and thus David created
what will eventually be the xenomorph
now the question with that is how could
he do that if the black liquid wiped out
all the animal life on the planet like
what animal DNA could be used to play
God with maybe Prometheus already gave
us that answer more gods remember we
already saw one engineer in hypersleep
on board the juggernaut it's possible
that there were other sleeping engineers
somewhere on the ship which David could
have experimented on during his 10 years
on the planet to produce these eggs
there's also a kind of out there theory
from alien universe that involves a
process called egg morphing egg morphing
was a deleted concept from the original
alien film in 1979 where a xenomorph can
transform organic material like human
body into a new egg
so like rather than cocooning a human
prisoner into an incubation pod for a
facehugger
they like keep cocooning it and turn it
into an egg that a facehugger would come
out of and I guess maybe David created
these eggs through the egg morphing
process but really I think there's a
simpler explanation remember in the
scene David told Orem that the eggs were
waiting for mother and while that could
mean they're waiting for like a host
body to incubate them David could be
hinting at a different kind of mother
really the rule of the alien movies is
where there's eggs there's breakfast
also an alien queen Ridley Scott
considers James Cameron's aliens to be
canon and in that movie of course we see
the alien queen laying these xenomorph
eggs that's where they come from
so if Ridley Scott plans on keeping the
Queen as the origin of these eggs where
did that Queen come from and where is
she an alien covenant one theory that I
find interesting is that the Queen was
the proto morph that popped out of Shaw
and like that Queen could have laid the
eggs underneath the engineer city
unleashing the facehuggers on the
Covenant crew remember if you looked
closely at that scene of Shaw singing
take me home in hologram you can kind of
make out the shape of a xenomorph or
facehugger tail in the hologram behind
her and maybe that belongs to a queen as
for where the queen is now she's right
behind you or she's somewhere beneath
the surface of the planet or maybe she
died off with
the animal life or maybe she'll show up
in a sequel like I feel like revealing
that alien queen backstory could be part
of Ridley Scott's plan for alien
awakening but for now it seems like the
main plan is to follow David's journey
to create the perfect organism now I
don't think alien covenant clearly
confirmed that he did that yet again
these portal morphs aren't exactly
Xenomorphs but this chilling final scene
shows david jacking up two alien embryos
and storing them in deep freeze on the
Covenant so clearly he's going to be
involved in a species ongoing evolution
probably using the human embryos and
sleeping covenant passengers as more
host to experiment on which will
inevitably lead to David's genetically
engineering a face hugger to somehow
impregnate his own Android body to spawn
the alien queen I figured it out guys
this is the most viable theory in this
whole video you're welcome okay that
covers the evolution of the xenomorph as
updated in Alien Covenant and hopefully
future alien movies will fill in these
missing links on the alien evolution
chain so if you liked this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rock stars
you can also contribute to us on patreon
thanks so much to all of our current
patrons especially Kenny Smith you can't
hit me up on twitter at EA boss with any
thoughts or questions maybe that you
have about alien covenant or follow new
rock stars on twitter at new rock stars
for updates on our videos ok thanks for
watching bye